wer weiß schon heute
morgen sind jeden tag
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
und wieder alles neu beginnt hey leute
könnten thomas unseren drummer der ist
das erste mal in berlin
erzähl mal wie empfindest du diese stadt
das ist ein gefühl das ist alles sehr
sehr beeindruckend weil sie einen doch
ein interessanter teil der deutschen
geschichte
wir sind hier mitten drin vor der mauer
ein geschichtlich sehr sagt man
intensiver platz
es war 1989 ich war acht jahre alt als
die mauer gefallen
ich war so klein und habe vor dem
fernseher gesessen weil meine eltern da
saßen und die fanden das total ist
vielleicht haben sie vor der glotze
geheult das ist alles woran ich noch
weiß es sind viele schlimme sachen
passiert mittlerweile geht es uns gut
ist und eine neue generation
es ist diese mauer man kennt geschichten
wir sind nicht schön
also wenn wir jetzt hier steht ist das
irgendwie ganz schön bemalt und schöne
wiese früher war es halt ganz schön
ätzend
was war hier dann alles so wenn ihr war
todesstreifen
selbstschussanlagen also wachtürmen mit
leuten drauf scharfschützen minenfeld
ziemlich unten
dann kam mir die hunde im portfolio
dann kam die wachtürme mit dem verminten
feld und der selbstschussanlagen
dann nochmal flächen sperren
dann kam der zaun und dann kam die
zweite mal dass man durfte halt nicht
rüber jetzt verstehe ich langsam warum
die leute auf der einen seite irgendwann
durchgedreht sind was natürlich ein
wahnsinniger freiheitsentzug ist ein
gefängnis
da gab es die östliche und westliche
hemisphäre da war ein eiserner vorhang
natürlich das ist völlig irre aktion
haben die gebracht wir haben ewig lange
tunnel gegraben unten aus irgendwelchen
kellern raus rüber vielleicht spricht
das für diese gewisse sorte
freiheitsdrang dass leute dinge machen
die wirklich nicht vernünftig sind weil
sie das verlangen haben da rauszukommen
ich habe von meinem papa damals ein
stück von der berliner mauer willkommen
das konnte man damals kaufen
das hat ihm in die hand gedrückt und
gesagt hier irgendwann wird es sehr viel
wert sein bzw ein sehr großes stück
geschichte ich habe es damals nicht
verstanden wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen
dass dieses ding hier ein riesiges
symbol ist dann ist es nicht nur
touristen attraktionen und nicht nur
schön bemalt sondern es ist ein
wahnsinnig wichtiges ding das natürlich
erhalten werden